hey guys it's mkbhd welcome back to
youtube tips episode number five this is
a video review or a video about how to
give honest video reviews totally uncut
probably uh but basically i've been
asked this question a lot uh in the
recent days or months that i've been
giving actual product reviews and
actually reviewing products that you
know the beats by dre that i've reviewed
the other ath m50 headphones i've
reviewed things like that people want to
know not just how to get products to
review
but how to review the products properly
and that second part is what i'm
covering right now
reviewing a product honestly is actually
one of the critical
parts of making a good video review you
can have all the most fancy camera work
in the world and all the the greatest
equipment for making the best video
possible but if the content of the video
is bad then it doesn't mean anything
so giving an honest video review is what
i would say is most about one key word
perspective
perspective is the way you view the
product and what is relative to other
things that you have used so i'll give
the beats by dre as an example right now
say you've been listening to your crappy
20 ipod headphones for the past year and
you finally saved up enough money to get
your first pair of beats by dre you've
looked at them for months you've read a
bunch of great reviews on the beats by
dre even and you finally picked them up
and they sound amazing so what are you
doing you review them you give them a 10
out of 10. now
the beats solo hds say you got the solo
hds are not a 10 out of 10 pair of
headphones but for you your honest
review can give them a 10 out of 10 and
here's why if you give them a 10 you
have to be able to give some sort of
perspective of what you've given them a
10 relative to
if you're following me so far so let
their viewers know that you've been
listening to 20 ipod headphones for the
past year
and when i listen to the beats by dre
that is 10 out of 10 sound and this is
the music i listen to and why it sounds
like a 10 out of 10. that's the kind of
relative rating you need to give your
products so i'll give another example uh
say you're reviewing the blue yeti pro
you've been using a
inbuilt microphone in the microphone in
your laptop for the past couple months
and you've saved up enough money for the
usb microphone called the yeti pro you
get it and it works absolutely amazing
and you give it a 10 out of 10 because
it just sounds so much better well
in your budget it might be a 10 out of
10 but like we already know there are
amazing microphones out there that would
make the yeti pro look like a three out
of ten so to give a fair honest review
you can rate the yeti pro at 10 out of
10 relative to what you've already
reviewed or what you've already used so
make sure your viewers know what you've
reviewed already or that you've already
used the inbuilt microphone on your
laptop so that
is youtube tip number five i would say
to give honest reviews you need to be
able to give perspective and let your
viewers know what you've already used
and how it relates to some other things
you use so that's a quick video i had to
put up just to let you guys know how i
rate my products so whenever you see an
eight and a half out of ten for me i'll
let you know what that's relative to and
what what is actually a 10 out of 10 on
my scale and a crap out of 10 on my
scale thanks for watching guys make sure
you give a thumbs up if this helped you
and i'll talk to you guys in the next
video
peace
[Music]
you